élections cantonales en lorraine la
meurthe et moselle est présenté comme le
seul département susceptibles de
basculer de droite à gauche
les deux prétendants à la présidence du
conseil général sont jacques baudot et
michele dean et chacun se présente dans
un canton très différents jacques baudot
président sortant et candidat udf dans
celui de nancy sud
michele dean et ps se présente lui dans
le canton de colombey-les-belles et les
deux hommes pro fort en leurs chances
portraits croisés gérard clavel thierry
gallet jacques baudot détient la
présidence du conseil général depuis dix
ans ses positions sur nancy sud sont
très fortes
face à lui cinq adversaires
anne-isabelle beaucaillou du mouvement
des citoyens
gérard baroin du fn jean christophe
fischer des verts olivier mergaux des
radicaux de gauche et le socialiste
jean-louis thiébert en 92 le ps n'avait
obtenu que 15 % sur ce canton se
présentait contre le président du
conseil général
c'est un pari difficile mais je crois
que il faut oser le pari difficile moi
je suis président du groupe des élus de
gauche elle la ville de nancy
je crois que c'est un enjeu important
pour la gauche à nancy michele dean et
lui aussi est très solidement implanté
sur son canton de colombey les belles
îles à trois adversaires sauveur violi
du fn
pierre guillaume du pc est une jeune
candidate rpr nadine morano qui ne fait
aucun complexe face au leader socialiste
et j'ai choisi comme slogan n'a audace
et vitalité pour notre compte on
l'audace parce que ça me caractérise l
invité parce que c'est ce que j'ai envie
d'apporter aux cantons de
colombey-les-belles donc pour moi c'est
un beau challenge et je compte bien tout
faire pour l'emporter dans ce scrutin 98
le conseil général de meurthe et moselle
sera renouvelée aux deux tiers et michel
dinet croit en ses chances de donner le
département à la
les changes ont quand même très
équilibré le jeu reste très joueurs on
sait très bien que l'élection
départementale
c'est à la fois une élection d'une
majorité mais c'est en même temps une
élection individuel jacques baudot c'est
que dans l'élection à la présidence du
conseil général
chaque voix pèsera très lourd avec une
inconnue supplémentaire
le résultat dans les quatre nouveaux
cantons du département
je joue de trois mois dans un sens
particulièrement de trois voix ou alors
vraiment à une voix près 6 et 7 à gauche
le saf le risque est passé
la campagne officielle des cantonales
débutera lundi et le 22 mars au soir on
saura si la meurthe et moselle reste à
droite
une passe à gauche